cattle trucks that serve as public
transport supermarket shelves empty of
all basic goods this is what Venezuela
under president Maduro has come to look
like when Nicolas Maduro took office
after Igor Chavez died in 2013 he
inherited his predecessors socialist
revolution mentioned champion social
justice and people power for all
Venezuelans yet before long Maduro
sought to tighten his own grip on power
he cracked down on dissenting voices
prominent opposition leaders were
arrested or put under house arrest when
the opposition gain control of
Venezuela's Parliament Maduro set up a
new Constituent Assembly that could
bypass Parliament the move sparked mass
protests many violently crushed by
police
in May last year Maduro was confirmed an
office in elections that were widely
seen as a sham many Western and Latin
American countries have refused to
recognize the result they said that you
were obliged to vote they said that
people were coerced it's a lack of
respect
although Parliament is now largely
toothless its leader Hwang Guido has
vowed to fight back we reaffirm the
illegitimate II of Nicolas Maduro as a
result this National Assembly as the
only legitimate power elected by the
Venezuelan people should assume the
representation of the people and it's
the people of Venezuela who continued to
suffer under Maduro a recession
exacerbated by economic mismanagement
has brought the country to its knees
it was once a wealthy oil nation and one
of Latin America's most prosperous
societies today more than half of
Venezuelans struggled to feed themselves
and their families
hyperinflation and a shortage of basic
goods have caused an unprecedented
humanitarian crisis that has driven
three million Venezuelans to flee the
country
and let's get more now from our
correspondent Ophelia harms who is
standing by in the region for us so
affiliate we have nicolas maduro
starting his second term as president in
Venezuela today how is this being
perceived in the region well at least 16
Latin America American countries as well
as the US and Canada have warned that
they do not recognize last year's
elections and therefore see this new
mandate as legitimate the so-called Lima
group a group that has been created to
discuss the Venezuelan problem in the
region have also warned that they will
not let any Venezuelan diplomats into
their countries any more they will
withdraw their own diplomats as well and
also freeze some of the Venezuelan
diplomats assets in their countries
this group has also called the National
Assembly the Venezuelan Parliament to
take over power until new elections can
take place in that country but as we saw
in the report the National Assembly's
powers have been seized by Maduro regime
it has been replaced by a Constituent
Assembly and he has also been holding
power of the supreme court that will be
swearing him in today different to what
the Constitution in Venezuela actually
establishes and given that what do you
see as the main challenges for his
administration in the coming six years
and is he likely to prioritize the
economy well he would say that he has
been prioritizing the economy all along
and and that this chaos has been created
by these sanctions from the outside but
the truth is that as we saw the
inflation is about to reach two million
percent and that has forced three
million Venezuelans to flee the country
due to the shortages the malnutrition
and the diseases spread all over the
country
he will also face more international
pressure from the community he has also
been starting to be investigated
by the international courts so because
they think that he has been committing
crime crimes against humanity and this
will be another challenge during the
next term of failure harms with a very
latest from Bogota thank you
you